[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno
buongiorno a tutti io sono elena lavezzi
ad oggi sono la responsabile del sud
europa di re volut che è una delle
aziende più grandi nel settore fintech
arrivo da un background di tecnologia
seppur applicata alla mobilità perché
tanti anni fa oramai ho aperto il
mercato italiano di di huber
dunque oggi vi voglio portare nel mio
mondo quello appunto del film tech
finanza e tecnologia
vediamo come quest'industria che è una
dell'industria che sta diventando più
rilevanti è nel mondo della tecnologia
abbatte le barriere riduce le distanze
tra di noi tra tra gli esseri umani
beh innanzitutto io in questa stanza
vedo tantissimi ragazzi molto giovani e
per fortuna loro per sfortuna mia loro
non si ricorderanno 20 anni fa come
erano diverse certe abitudini mentre io
appunto me lo ricordo molto bene come
facevamo diversamente certe cose prima
dell'avvento di internet e quanto questo
abbia effettivamente impattato nelle
nostre attività quotidiane e abbia
abilitato certe attività pensate a a
quanto si sono ridotte le distanze tra
le persone nel mondo grazie ad esempio
al fatto che possono comunicare in
maniera gratuita e istantanea
grazie alle app di messaggistica ad
esempio piuttosto che è social network
oppure pensate ad esempio al fatto che
possiamo lavorare da casa
da remoto con la nostra azienda con i
nostri colleghi in in tempo reale oppure
che possiamo gestire la nostra casa da
remoto grazie alla domotica decidendo
tutte le funzioni che appunto vogliamo
che si attivino quando noi non ci siamo
addirittura pensate pensate quanto è
incredibile tutto questo è quanto ci
sembrava lontano fino a pochissimi anni
fa
voglio farvi vedere questo contenuto che
non è mio ma che spesso viene riproposto
proprio per far capire quanto nel tempo
più velocemente le tecnologie impattino
su milioni di utenti dunque sempre più
velocemente in realtà pensiamo agli
aeroplani ci hanno messo 68 anni per
raggiungere 50 milioni di clienti
pensiamo ad esempio alle carte di
credito ne hanno messi 28 b anni per
avere i primi 50 milioni di utenti
facebook ha impiegato tre anni
poche mungo che è un gioco che è andato
di moda qualche tempo fa cioè su
diciannove giorni è in generale
pensate che l'innovazione e la
tecnologia portano un valore non solo
perché riducono le distanze tra di noi
ma anche perché ci fanno risparmiare un
sacco di tempo
pensate al fatto che non andiamo più
nelle agenzie di viaggio per prenotare
magari passiamo ore ore a guardare i
cataloghi e le mete ma semplicemente
dalla nostra scrivania prenotiamo tutto
in poco tempo
oppure pensate ad esempio allo spazio
che le innovazioni e le tecnologie ci
fanno risparmiare
pensate ad esempio a quanti archivi
avevamo bisogno prima per salvare i
nostri documenti adesso è tutto su
chiavetta oppure oppure in cloud oppure
pensate che prima avevamo bisogno magari
di un oggetto usavamo una volta soltanto
poi lo mettevamo in casa e gli rimaneva
perché non ci serviva più
adesso grazie alle app si può noleggiare
tutto di fatto dunque io noleggio tutto
e si ribalta anche un po il significato
del del possesso
oggi parliamo appunto di finte dunque la
finanza e la tecnologia in sé
e vi racconterò vi parlerò un po appunto
di denaro e di finanza ma non finanza i
temi difficili quali le azioni gli
investimenti bond la finanza che impatta
nelle nostre vite quotidiane che noi
tocchiamo quotidianamente pensiamo al
denaro
fate una riflessione ma voi direste mai
ai vostri amici quanto prendete di
stipendio o quanto avete speso per
acquistare un oggetto che desideravate
tanto
la verità è che per noi in particolare
in italia a parlare di denaro è un tabù
è un tabù nel senso che tutti abbiamo a
che fare con il denaro ovviamente
utilizziamo di continuo tutti i giorni
fa parte della nostra vita ma alcuni
pensano che sia maleducato parlarne
altri pensano che sia un argomento
sgradevole e preferiamo evitare ma
questo parte appunto da una poca
confidenza col tema una poca educazione
finanziaria
pensate che gli studenti italiani
registrano dei risultati bassi rispetto
alla media dell'osservatorio per lo
sviluppo economico inferiori rispetto a
questa media per quanto riguarda
l'educazione finanziaria
un altro dato che io ho trovato molto
interessante che vi voglio condividere e
che black rock che è un'azienda di
investimenti molto molto famosa a
livello globale stima che più di un
italiano su due
singer busi c'e e si stressa quando
parla di lavoro o di denaro ma
incredibilmente solo il 40 per cento di
noi ha già iniziato a risparmiare per la
pensione contro il 63 per cento della
media globale oggi appunto vi porto
all'interno del film tech
da dove nasce da due nasce il feedback
il fintech nasce undici anni fa dunque
nasce
undici anni fa cosa e successo nel 2008
sono stato il crac finanziario ed è da
lì che è nata veramente questa nuova
industria che oggi ricopre un ruolo
tanto importante nell'innovazione
proprio da quel momento lì prima non
esisteva neanche questa parola si
parlava di aziende di pagamenti non
esisteva la parola fintech quel crack ha
comportato due cose non solo appunto una
grandissima crisi economica che ha penso
abbia impattato un po su tutti noi
in tutto il mondo ma anche un crack
della fiducia dei clienti delle banche
degli istituti gli istituti finanziari
nei confronti appunto di questi istituti
che fino ad allora erano corte erano
stati considerati molto solidi questa
cosa ha portato a mettere in discussione
tantissime certezze dal punto di vista
appunto di quali tipi di servizi
scelgo per far gestire le mie finanze
dunque non solo ha portato i clienti che
magari erano affezionati alla propria
banca ha invece valutare altri servizi
altre altre aziende per i propri
risparmi per i propri conti ma ha
portato anche a tantissime persone
sicuramente con una predisposizione
imprenditoriale a valutare il fatto di
creare da zero dei servizi seppure senza
avere un non avendo un background un
percorso magari in finanza ma persone
come noi che hanno detto qui c'è un
potenziale
qui c'è la possibilità di creare da zero
dei servizi che ribaltino il paradigma
mettano al centro il cliente treno delle
esperienze d'uso tramite le app molto
intuitive molto semplici abbassino
addirittura riducano i costi e mettano
in condizione gli utenti di fare tutto
indipendentemente ovunque si trovino nel
mondo dalla loro atto in maniera
istantanea tra l'altro pensate
questo che impatto positivo può avere
anche nel farci prendere confidenza con
le nostre finanze
se io riesco a vedere molto più
facilmente quanto spendo in quali
categorie posso utilizzare senza
spendere costi aggiuntivi diverse valute
nel mondo e posso inviare denaro senza
tempi di attesa
questo può errata educarci molto di più
appunto all'utilizzo all'utilizzo di
vitale voglio farvi qualche esempio
concreto di come effettivamente il
fintech abbatta le barriere tre mesi fa
tra mesi fa alla nostra azienda ha
aperto la sede in un nuovo continente
dunque noi abbiamo la nostra sede
principale in europa abbiamo lanciato il
mercato dell'australia pensate e per la
prima volta questa cosa per me scusate
ma è è incredibile per la prima volta è
stato possibile inviare in maniera
istantanea e gratuita soldi dall'altra
parte del mondo in un altro continente
io ho vissuto tanto all'estero per
lavoro o per studio e se questa
possibilità ci fosse stata quando vivevo
all'estero io ma sapete quante
commissioni avrei risparmiato quando mia
mamma mi mandava i soldi per farmi
studiare all'estero oppure semplicemente
non avremmo più dovuto pianificare il
fatto che mi doveva mandare con totti e
giorni di anticipo ad esempio dunque per
me questa è una rivoluzione caldamente
potente che veramente può impattare in
maniera significativa su tutte le
persone immaginate quanti di voi magari
studiano all'estero oppure stanno per
partire per un erasmus hanno i figli che
stanno studiando lavorando all'estero
allora trovo una cosa molto potente
questa si chiama vera è una vera
rivoluzione che importa nella mia vita
quotidiana ad esempio oppure pensate al
crowdfunding pensate a come è facile per
l'ideatore di un progetto mettere su una
piattaforma appunto la propria idea che
può essere culturale di tipo culturale
economico sociale e raccogliere fondi da
privati che credono nell idea in cambio
vogliono una quota di questo progetto
oppure provare il prodotto per primi
dunque a quanto
il semplice diventa sostenere un
progetto e diventare anche investitori
ma anche con piccole somme di denaro
senza essere dei dei professionisti
pensate anche a quando ci sono delle
catastrofi naturali come ad esempio la
foresta dell'amazzonia che quest'estate
come sappiamo ha subito importanti
importanti incendi
e quanto è stato facile fare donazioni
anche con pochi centesimi tramite un'app
per quando veramente su un pulsante è
più veloce ancora di mandare un sms
questa donazione arriva per il 100 per
cento al destinatario in questo caso le
persone che si battevano per dare fine a
queste a questi incendi pensate quanto
diventa più veloce anche per tutti noi
anche per i giovani senza dover fare un
bonifico appunto mandare un sms
sostenere una charity un'associazione di
questo tipo come per questa catastrofe
per mille altre
quando noi pensiamo all'educazione
finanziaria
sicuramente ci vengono in mente gli
adulti al massimo gli adolescenti a
secondo voi non sarebbe bellissimo se i
bambini potessero già cominciare ad
avere dimestichezza con questo tema
tramite delle app molto intuitive molto
semplici dove invece che avere la
paghetta di 5 euro settimanale come
avevo io come avevate sicuramente voi
per i più fortunati magari 10 euro al
massimo cartacea in tasca avere un app
dove io ho la mia paghetta virtuale
inizio a imparare a risparmiare se
voglio fare il regalino a un amichetto
ad esempio lungo ovviamente dei conti
per bambini legati al conto del genitore
tramite che un genitore può decidere se
il bambino può prelevare o meno può fare
acquisti o meno può fare acquisti
ricorrenti o meno intanto però a dare in
mano questo almeno uno strumento che gli
faccia prendere dimestichezza con questo
tema che con cui dovrà avere a che fare
per tutta la sua vita e tutti i giorni
tutti i giorni della sua vita e voglio
ancora dire questa cosa pensate che
mastercard ha fatto una ricerca su 15
paesi e cosa è emerso che ci sono 600
milioni di persone che hanno uno
smartphone ma non possono aprire un
conto corrente 600 milioni solo in 15
paesi
pensate che impatto positivo può avere
dare a queste persone la possibilità in
pochi click di aprirsi un conto iniziare
a a potersi gestire le proprie finanze
trovo una cosa molto molto potente e
vediamo proprio come va di pari passo il
fatto che ci sia un innovazione
tecnologica e finanziaria con
l'evoluzione degli smartphone che ahimè
sono fondamentali per questo tipo di
innovazioni e rivoluzioni
io penso di avervi portato un pochino
dentro al mio mondo e avervi fatto
capire quanto il fintech possa
effettivamente ridurre le barriere e
impattare positivamente nella nostra
vita con qualche esempio però da
operatrice del sistema vi confesso una
cosa ci sono altre attività in cui noi
che lavoriamo in questa industria non
riusciamo ad avere un impatto non
riusciamo a portare questa tecnologia a
sostituire la moneta incerte a in certe
attività in particolare tre me ne sono
venuto in mente dove la moneta resistera
e non penso
sparirà sparirà mai queste tre attività
sono beh la moneta quando la mettiamo
nel carrello quando cantiamo il gratta e
vinci e quando vogliamo fare testo
atroce con con i nostri amici grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]